في عام 2022، كان هناك عدد من المنازل
التي تم بيعها بأكثر من 10 ملايين
دولار، مما جعل دبي رابع
أكثر الأسواق السكنية الفاخرة نشاطًا في العالم،
وذلك وفقًا
لشركة عقارية عالمية مثل فرانك وأنا هنا
للتحقق من هذه الملايين المتعددة
يجب أن تقدم المنازل بالدولار
[موسيقى]
إنها التحفة الفنية، إنها
بصراحة، فما هو
السعر، دعنا نتخلص
من ذلك، لذا فإن السعر المطلوب
هو 125 مليون دولار أمريكي يقع على مساحة 40
ألف قدم مربع من الأرض في برايم ساكيم
جميرا  الموقع، المنزل عبارة عن تحفة
معمارية حقًا، سؤالي هو
ما مدى الطلب على عقارات
مثل هذه في دبي في الوقت الحالي،
الطلب الحالي مرتفع للغاية لأننا
نعلم أن السوق قد تحول بشكل لا يصدق.
أنا أحب هذه الطاولة تمامًا، إنها
عقيق أبيض
مع  ترصيع الذهب نعم
استثنائي للغاية،
هناك ما قيمته حوالي 15 مليون دولار
من الأعمال الفنية في المنزل حاليًا
شهد سوق العقارات الفاخرة في دبي ارتفاعًا قياسيًا بمقدار 44 ارتفاعًا في
أسعار المنازل في العام الماضي مما يجعله أعلى
مستوى عالميًا وفقًا لـ Knight Frank
السوق هل تعرف المزيد  لقد
تضاعف حجمها على مدار العام،
وفي الواقع تحولت دبي من كونها
سوقًا إقليمية ذات
أهمية إقليمية من حيث نوع
السوق من الدرجة الأولى إلى أن تصبح في
الواقع في العام الماضي على مدار الـ
12 شهرًا الماضية أكبر سوق  سوق الرهن العقاري
على مستوى العالم
وفقًا لقاعدة الوساطة المالية في دبي،
تصدر المشترون من شركة بيتر هومز في المملكة المتحدة قائمة
الجنسيات التي تستثمر في هذا
السوق تليها الهند وروسيا.
أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس يطرحون
السؤال حول ما إذا كانت هذه
فقاعة مصطنعة أم أنها
طلب مصطنع يأتي من خلاله
ويقارنه  يعود الأمر إلى المخاطر التي شهدناها
خلال الأزمة المالية العالمية، فقد
مرت دبي بعدد من الدورات على مدار
15 عامًا الماضية، حيث
نضجت الأسواق وشهدت
ارتفاع الأسعار وشهدت انخفاض الأسعار، وأعتقد أن
الفرق هذه المرة  هل أعتقد أنه من
العدل أن نقول إن نمو الأسعار عند
هذا المستوى ليس مستدامًا، كما تعلم
أننا لا نتوقع أن نرى نموًا في الأسعار
قريبًا مما رأيناه
مؤخرًا هذا العام إذا نظرت إلى ما
يحدث عالميًا وقد شهدته معظم الأسواق الرئيسية
تصحيحات الأسعار أعتقد أنه في
حالة الجهاز، أعتقد أن هناك حجة يجب
تقديمها مفادها أن التحول في
التسعير في الماضي لمدة عامين أو
ثلاثة أعوام هو في الواقع انعكاس لسفينة في
المدينة، ومن ثم فإن الأمر كما هو عليه الآن
استقطاب المواهب الأجنبية عالمياً